we were also very good friends with mr.
Paul Rudd Paul Rudd yes who big friend
of the show what's this Bishop because
your show yeah he's a great guy we've
known him for years but you guys are
very tight and now he's catapulted into
superstardom with the ant-man phenomenon
yeah he's an Avenger he's an Avenger
yeah so I don't hear but I don't hear
from him anymore really
very thick yeah but now he's you know
he's friends with Thor yeah yeah okay he
got you I'm told he was giving you
dieting advice well this is this is what
happened he and I are almost the exact
same age I am one month older than him
and I reached a certain age I'm 50 and a
few years ago I I needed to lose weight
I mean it was just one of these things
that I have a bad back and they said you
need to lose weight for your bad back
and I asked him how did you get so
shredded for ant-man do you know the I
mean he's he was oh yeah I mean when
you're an Avenger and you have to take
your I'm talking like someone who knows
who's been an Avenger
hey when you're an Avenger which I never
was you could be Loki you could have
been cast as Loki yeah
your Loki s I could be the Invisible
Woman that's the whole difference
different hold it that's fantastic sorry
but yeah you have to be shredded so what
was his secret well he gave me first of
all the reason I reached out to him and
and not thanks for calling me now you
know we're also friends and who do you
call to get shredded you Paul Paul Rudd
well the thing is we're the same age
were this similar ethnic stock so I
figured like that's a I would never look
at shredded as him but like I could
that's in in that direction that's
attainable sure and he gave me this diet
that had to do a lot you know it's it's
just basic sense of like avoiding breads
and carbs and eating and having protein
shakes in the late afternoon and in the
late morning so as to like suppress your
appetite when you have me or whatever it
worked I lost 15 20 pounds as a
broadcaster so as I did not get that
applause at home yeah yeah my kids used
to call me fat daddy and now they know
they called you fat daddy well and now
they don't so that's exciting my kids
used to call me unfunny daddy and they
still do my kids taught me that too
so one of the problems with losing
weight especially if you're on TV is
that sometimes if you go too far you you
you can get a little gaunt in the face
you ever worry about that like people
can look you can lose some of the fat in
your face and it doesn't look good on
there was a point when I that some of
the people I worked with thought I'd
lost too much weight and they told me so
but generally speaking as you know the
cameras very unforgiving and I was
getting older and I was getting jollier
and well I mean as I know
well you as I know know yeah I find this
camera portrays me as the handsome man
that I am
[Applause]